i just wanted to get to y'all's thoughts
on this
jake the problem child paul versus tyron
the chosen one woodley ii fight
if you've seen it
jake paul
i mean
put tyron with it sleep with 50 seconds
left in the sixth round which is crazy
because even being a jake paul fan i had
tyrone woodley winning at that point
but
if y'all watch it i just want to get
jaws views and thoughts on it
and
hey have a great day hope y'all are
gonna have a merry christmas
thank you little red riding hood
um i have a question all right so i'm
not i'm not a fight aficionado nothing
like that you guys know i don't like
this kind of stuff but i did see that
violent thing you saw you saw the clip i
saw the clip and i was like wow but let
me ask you this yeah
who is
is canelo like a the premier boxer right
now best in the world
number one all right so if you're a
fighter
would you take a fight with canelo with
two weeks notice absolutely not right
and why is that
because the level he's at i mean
his last fight a guy did do it on i
think a three-week notice and you're
also talking about a guy who's been
boxing since he was eight i know but
what i'm saying though is that what i'm
saying is
no pedophilia dog sorry guys
trying to give him the facts you know i
know but what i'm saying is like it's a
to me
it's a lack of respect for like to think
that yeah i'm just going to take this
fight within two weeks well hold up
whitley was training he thought tommy
fury was going to pull out so he's been
training it wasn't like that makes sense
that makes it even worse because to me
i think it's time for jake paul to fight
a real boxer because he's gonna really
hurt somebody define real boxers though
i'm saying somebody that's like because
this guy that he fought wasn't
necessarily a boxer right
about a hall of fame
uh ufc fighter i know but isn't bach
just because you're good at ufc doesn't
mean that is it you'll see a combination
of all that stuff it's different but at
the same time too like
so he was supposed to fight tommy fury
right who's supposedly a quote-unquote
boxer tommy fury is an easier fight than
woodley for him
you think so i don't know it didn't look
to me
my ignorance my my naivete about this
it looked like
that dude was not ready to be in the
ring with him yeah like because like you
know anybody does this right anybody can
get caught at any particular time right
anybody no matter who you are and i just
i don't know if that guy had the it
didn't seem like he had the techniques
to like protect himself i mean he could
have killed him man he could have killed
him look that was a vicious ass hit man
vicious they dr first of all they
dressed up little tyrone as a day you
know they dress him up like a damn
little christmas ornament out there like
a little uh christmas ornament that's
something you'd buy at like a gay gas
station like a little santa thought
because i'm a little santa thought
i mean whoever dressed him right you
know
gas station
is it called 69.
phillips 69 bro
so you know they dressed him up out the
gate you know they had him looking a
little christopher robin out there out
the gate
then
you know good and well brendan that
tyron woodley has not been the same guy
for the past three years i don't think
he's not he doesn't want to fight in his
last six fights he didn't say this out
of total respect he was oh and four in
his last four fights in ufc i don't
think he is mentally in the same place
that he was spot on so it's almost like
beating on somebody that is not mentally
well that's what i personally felt like
i don't see i i wouldn't say mentally
well i think it's like beating on
somebody who is just doing it for the
payday
like you know what i'm saying like he's
not doing the same things that got him
to the world championship level well
that's what i'm saying though he didn't
look like he he was ready for the fight
and i just feel like i think that jake
paul at at this point and now it's like
you need to fight
be a be fight like a guy that's boxing
here's the thing though all the hate on
jake paul and stuff no this is no
happening no no i know i get it
everyone's i'll fight a real box not
like that go go to any whoever name a
box that you guys like tyson fury
mike tyson evander holyfield any mexican
dude sure julio chavez senior junior
whoever the [ __ ] you want canelo their
first four fights they were fighting
cans that's how it should be i know jake
paul's first four fights are way more
difficult than anything your favorite
boxer fought well you have to give the
guy credit at some point he also had in
his contract you can't knock me out so
no
that's not true
that's not real
good that's been debunked
yeah i was jealous of the rest that
tyron woodley got i mean you saw him go
to i mean i i you can't even get sleep
like that anymore as an adult five
minutes
yeah that was like oh dawg i was like
damn that wrapped me up in a hampton inn
son let's do this boy yeah
we can figure that out you come out here
with the [ __ ] you give me i'll i'll give
you a quick nap brother if that's what
you're looking for
dude
that's bad and look at the raft too the
ref is like oof yeah the ref's like this
yeah yeah we got the rest of the emotion
like yeah this is done
yeah but listen you do that to woodley
like now to your point like you want to
see him fight a real fighter quote on
quote boxer you're gonna get it you
flatline woodley are you gonna get over
it okay here's let me ask you this
though let me i'm sorry you just remind
me both of y'all theo everybody in here
that's into fighting all right so let's
say he wants to fight canelo who is like
the chain not happening i'll go but
listen okay this is my whole point
it is a lose-lose for canelo 100 all
right and it's a win for jake no matter
what right cause like even if he just
getting in the ring well that's logan
paul floyd mayweather no but but that's
different because
floyd is he already retired and he
already did that other ridiculous fight
with the other guy that he could have
demolished but he for the money he let
it go you know you know what i mean
george orwell or whatever no no the uh
conor mcgregor conor mcgregor he could
have he could have killed conor mcgregor
in the ring and he just let him like he
made it he made it entertaining that was
wwf yeah okay but what i'm saying is for
like canelo can only win if he does this
if if as soon as jake paul gets in the
ring he has to demolish him in a way
that
hey man this levels to this canelo would
never do it he makes too much money
what's up but to put on but what i'm
saying though is like
like when i right
it was center in seventh grade and i had
to face a female nose tackle it was a
lose-lose for me yes even though she
should beat drastic no no i shut her
down
no one cares nick's not picking that
[ __ ] not a big deal
she was she was about twice my size and
i cut block her the whole time but she
didn't get any tactics oh no but it
wasn't it wasn't stuck
on top of me every time all right all
right jeff saturday but it would be like
a um it would be like a social
influencer starting to do comedy and
then he's now co-headlining with
chappelle yeah yeah yeah you know what i
mean and then yeah there'll be a victory
even if you're ready or not you'll be
like i did it i worked my way and i got
this guy unless you get knocked out in
30 seconds
the paul's the pauls have put themselves
in a great position yeah you know a
great business position it's a great
business move it was before the holiday
people are sick and people are curious
people want to
you know entertain
woodley's just doesn't let go with the
hands he just it's not his universe
and uh without that man
but bethea does that imply then that
he's not
proficient in boxing enough to agree yes
100 percent with somebody that like no
he's only four he's only 4-0 though so
these people
don't fight like canelo and [ __ ] i'm
saying woodley is not proficient in
boxing
yeah that's my question
it looked as if like it looked as if
like that guy because even that move
that whatever he did to make him
yeah whatever he did the dude almost was
like okay then he just went like take my
face and i was like god damn you see
that in slow-mo you got paige though and
that's why some people think it was he
took a fall some people that's not you
too
some people
they're stupid
you don't know i know for a fact i know
woodley very well trust me he did not
take a fall as your boy dustin poirier
if woodley took a fall he he's really
close to woodley anybody knows woodley
trust me but he ain't saying hey i'll
take a fall you can flatline me in the
front why would he say that and ruin my
career and now the chance for him
getting signed anywhere else is not good
it's so i want to see him fight again
what was the payday though how much did
he get millions probably millions
millions
and jake actually gave him jake because
of the rumors of the whole five hundred
thousand dollars old stretcher
jake actually put in the contract that
tyler woodley if tyron really could
knock him out if not jake out he'll give
him 500 000 extra that was actually in
their contract
these boys playing with some loot yeah i
wish it was i wish it was all or nothing
you know i wish it was like let's say
the the thing is like a 50 million
dollar thing you would go and get 50.
you know you say you're gonna get like
10 to pay your fees and all your people
you get that but it's like imagine if
the fight was like you get you know um
if it's 50 million you get 47 million if
you win and the other person gets three
i think these [ __ ] were
fighting
ufc is kind of like that ufc is kind of
like that yeah but it's not the same
amount of money though right uh at the
higher levels it is oh wow yeah i think
look man these guys did it they put the
show on again it's a great show to see
it you know and it's yeah i'm excited to
see what's next
well he said le'veon bell they said
le'veon bell last night now no do all
i'm saying is y'all boys are stupid
listen i'm saying this they need to put
some respect on jake paul's name
yeah that's my point i don't know that's
what i'm saying like you know you i
don't was he really training like you
take the fight like come on man i think
it's like like even if
to me it's like if if i'm gonna fight
say canelo you you're gonna need six
months like what's up what's a a proper
training a camp just four years like
eight weeks eight weeks of proper
training but you know what what's that's
that term they always say styles make
fights correct right so
what about tyrone woodley style
made him think that oh i'ma go i can
hang in the ring with jake because jake
has no experience and woodley has a ton
of experience in the ufc that's what
they were thinking and what they knocked
out plenty of people yeah
do you have the again i don't like that
but again i don't like that comparison i
don't think i don't think boxing and ufc
need they need to stop comparing the two
it needs to need that needs to end
because it's not the same
yeah but i think it's just these two
it's an interesting thing you're like
this guy has a lot of fighting
experience it's just guys
what's that i said you're right
sorry you're right though yeah it's just
enough there's enough curiosity there
but i think the curiosity is it might
start wearing off or
he might just continue to beat uh
urban men from different sports which is
what he's doing
y'all need to get a real brother or get
a freaking vato in there dawg i think
dude i know nine dudes that work at a
car wash in tucson that'll freaking
definitely get go 12 rounds they got
some hands giving them hands you tell me
you boys want to watch jake paul versus
nate diaz jake paul versus conor
mcgregor jake paul versus anderson silva
now i'd watch all of those we'd all paid
for
[Music]